B
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci comment ça va pas mal vous bien il
est pas mal hein Frid il est très ça va
je content de vous voir il
est com il est beau je suis là regarde
ça va c'est pas mal la bebar à la à la
la PAL pas mal pouri
non col de be il a fait cour il a fait
cour non je teste des trucs ils ont eu
des
problèmes bon après il y a quand même
mieux comme comparaison quo ça va hy
bien toi ça hy bien il est beau gosse
hein ok bon comment ça va je suis très
content d'être avec vous VO il y a du
dossier cette semaine il y a beaucoup de
dossiers y compris sur Cyril donc il va
passer une bonne soirée on commence
d'abord avec le susbou de la semaine et
oui parce que il y en a un qui veut
absolument une augmentation du coup bah
il fait tout pour vous caresser dans le
sens du poil son commence son prénom
commence par Jean il finit par Michel
JeanMichel quelle d'cade elles sont
belles
çais donc là vous voyez il y a Mar et cy
qui joue mais écoutez bien les réactions
de je en off vous les a pas entendu à
l'antenne
celll c'était bien tiré pourtant céit
bien tiré
che
nul magnifique
il y a du vent du vent
nul
nul oh là là j'ai
cru vous êtes bon chef quand
même ça s joué à
rien
oh j'ai jou à 1 degr
quoi non
c'est
mauvaisel relou oh là
[Applaudissements]
là pr
premier c'est fini
dégage c'est fini
dégage onadore on
l'adore incroyable c'est c'est pas mal
en parlant de Jean-Michel en parlant de
Jean-Michel la semaine dernière vous
vous souvenez on avait montré dans un
Magneto qu'il était un peu vieux parce
qu'il avait une vanne il voulait la
répéter absolument à tout le monde et
bien cette semaine il a passé un step il
est parti répéter la même vanne à tout
le monde sauf qu'il a passé un step sur
l'échelle de la lourdeur c'est le
perroquet de la semaine mais très relou
quand même j'adore
[Musique]
j'adore pas passé la semaine à
Versailles la semaine
[Musique]
dernière pas semaine
dernière as pas passé la semaine
versa eu cette alerte à la
bombe cette aler
[Applaudissements]
la regard et bon là il a même essayé
avec sia la coiffeuse qui
malheureusement n'a pas compris la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
VAN
[Applaudissements]
mag
quoi
il y a un chonqueur qu'on adore Cyril
mais qui est un petit Boulard en ce
moment il est spécialiste des enquêtes
et de la danse classique c'est Jacques
cardose ah mon Jacky mon JAC le problème
avec Jacques c'est que lorsqu'on lui
fait un compliment bah il en est fier
peut-être un peu trop fier mais ça reste
quand même l'artiste de la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
semaine là vendredi non vendredi tu es
là tu as vu mon mon
show il se passe un truc incroyable
la il sont V me voir ils m'ont dit tu
verrais tu verrais la
courbe je te j donc là ja est comme sur
sa presta vous l'avez vu n'hésite pas en
parler à tous ses petits copains
regardez comment il a même insisté avec
Kelly à
côtésumentce que quand je me suis mis à
chanter au
début il para que la courbe elle est
comme ça crois
pas c'est
drôle alors je prends pas du pour un
chanteur mais du coup ça commence à
travailler donc je demande je deme si je
peux aller voir pour lui proposer tous
les vendredis je commence par un
live
vendred ja card il est heureux on dirait
un gosse de 5 ans il dit que quand a
fait Johnny les audiences é comme ça
bravo faut que tu le
refasses tu vas le refaire tu vas le
refaire tu vas le refaire ou oui on le
refera ou et si tu me payes la chirurgie
je veux bien faire Michael
Jackson on va on va continuer sur
c'est bon avant de repartir Cyril mon
extrait préféré de la semaine vous savez
à la rentrée quand on est à l'école on
fait l'appel et parfois il y a des noms
ou voilà on peut rigoler un petit peu
sauf qu'ici bah on n pas à l'école on
est sur un plateau de télé c'est filmé
Cyril il y a des caméras exemple si je
vous dis monsieur prouto qu'on a reçu la
semaine dernière est hyper sympa je
l'adore ou un intervenant de qualité oui
vous avez écouté ce qu'il a dit j'adoré
ce gar mais j'adoré ce g j' dit vous
rigoler mais vous avez aussi écouté ce
qu'a dit monsieur absolument c'est
passionnant guume aussi bien sûr vous
l'avez écouté bon et bien réponse en
image ce sont les sales gosses de la
[Musique]
semaine on va vous donner quelques
conseils avec Lucas pruto qui est
spécialiste en défense
antiqueite alors là pendant la pub
monsieur prouto arrive bonsoir bonsoir
et la cyile et les chroniqueurs savent
très bien qu'il ne vont pas du tout
assumer la
séquence dire son nom famille tu pe dire
tu ne peux pas dire son nom de famille
vous auriez peut-être dû écouter ce
conseil cy car l'émission va être longue
très
longuenous on est très heureux d'être
ensemble et de se voir il est 20h on est
en direct on rigole beaucoup les pub
avec ça va ça va très
bien vous êtes avec nous merci pour
votre invitation alors vous entend pas
bien est-ce qu'on entend bien
[Rires]
monsieur
c'est faux faux livreur faux serrurier
faux voisin oui repère non mais c'est
c'est du repage ils ont vu que vous
étiez là après sans doute qui reste à
côté du domicile pour avoir vos heures
d'entrée de sorti il repè effectivement
ou ouais
et ah ouais donc là
oua
bon allez maintenant faut se calmer on
est plus à la maternelle quoi que un mot
suffit pour que ça reparte j'avais
entendu dire qu'il y avait des gaz
dispersant c'est quoi des gaz dispersant
monsieur
[Rires]
Bro et là on finit avec le classique la
mauvaise foie de Cyrille et hop on
rejette la fauteure
Guillaume Guillaume vous sortez vous
sortez les deux vous sortezard vous
sortez allez sortez sortez allez
dépêchez mais on a rien
faitver
S
jeés et en plus il était super mais bon
voilà c'était voilà cétait c'est voilà
c'est normal merci en tout cas Jérém
d'avoir été avec nous merci j vous venz
nous voir plus souvent volonti jé je c
ser bon ur un peu tu vois un peu sais il
amène un truc tu vois classe il
augmenter niveau c'est sympa pour nous
quand même sypa j'ai sor la vous voyez
la classe je suis désolé merci
incroyable de le remettre après P va REM
dans un instant tout de
suite